[Music]  bill cosby found guilty on thursday the  80 year olds comedian was convicted on  three counts of aggravated indecent  assault for drugging and sexually  assaulting andrea constand in 2004 Cosby  faces up to ten years in prison on each  count the jury composed of seven men and  five women deliberated for less than two  days before determining their verdict  the case against Cosby centered on  testimony from constand a former  employee with Temple University women's  basketball team she testified that Cosby  a powerfull trustee at Temple drugged  her and sexually assaulted her when she  visited his home to ask for career  advice although dozens of women have  accused Cosby of sexual misconduct only  konstanz  allegations resulted in criminal charges  [Music]  you